yeah I'm standing 15 feet off the ground
the storm just completely flattened this
Forest
can't even see the end of that oh come
back from Alaska and this is what we
find
oh I've got a lot of work to do
[Music]
[Applause]
well we've been traveling and filming a
lot this year so it's been almost nine
months since I've been on this property
and the road has absolutely been
swallowed up by vegetation
foreign
[Applause]
looks like a tornado touch down here
oh my goodness this is where we parked
the trailer it looks like there's half a
dozen trees right there we'll have to
bust out the chainsaw before I can even
Park the trailer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I put down about nine gallons of weed
killer and we're gonna give that a few
days and see if it gets rid of the grass
or not
foreign
let's check out the damage it's been
about a week since I sprayed the
herbicide down on the road and you can
see there's a stark difference between
what I treated and what I didn't treat
but there's still little patches of
green which I seem to have missed so I'm
gonna go back and spray again and really
focus on the stuff that doesn't look
wilted
well next thing on my agenda is to take
care of
all of this we've got so many trees down
on the property I also got these big old
brush piles to deal with and I want to
get rid of those and burn up what I can
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a pretty good pile of coals I got
there I think I'm gonna start cooking
some dinner
yeah that pile of coals right there Big
Slab of pork shoulder here and I've got
it all seasoned and wrapped up in tin
foil I'm going to bury it in those coals
for about two hours we're gonna have
pulled pork sandwiches tonight
well that's cooking I'm gonna go ahead
and start chopping up all these logs
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
got a nice pile of firewood
got that all cleared up I accomplished
just enough today that I feel like I can
do this
Sun's starting to set so I'm gonna grab
the shovel and see if my pork's done
I don't know about this coals weren't as
hot as I wanted
hmm it's not bad but it ain't fall off
the bone yet
oh that's looking good
buns there
how's that for perfectly toasted sweet
Memphis style barbecue sauce butter
pickles and we got coleslaw
man that doesn't look too bad at all
doesn't it
[Music]
there we go got my bed already but I'm
gonna go hang out by the fire it is a
beautiful beautiful night
well good morning everyone I think it's
time to get a fire going get some
breakfast made
now I want this fire to turn into a bed
of coals as quickly as possible that's
why I got a bunch of those half inch to
one inch diameter sticks get a good pile
of those those turn into coals really
quick and easy
[Music]
uh
-huh
all right
oh that was good
all right I think it's time to get to
work I've got a lot of downed trees I
need to clear up and the question is
what am I going to do with them I only
need so much firewood so I think I'm
going to build a little bit of a shed
here to store all of my stuff so it
keeps it out of the weather uh first we
need to clean this spot up a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got this spot done now I need to work on
that spot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
set aside I think it's time to start
building a shed for my tools
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
got a lot done but I'm starting to get
hungry so I think I'm gonna go and start
making some dinner here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
soup right there
all righty
oh that feels good
time to do the dishes
oh
it is an absolute beautiful night
I'm just gonna sit here by the fire and
relax for a little bit
I'm going to bed
well it is a beautiful cold crisp
morning but it smells like rain and you
can see the clouds overhead and I think
we're going to get rained on today I
better finish this shelter so I can put
all of our stuff out of the rain I don't
really want to waste time making an
elaborate breakfast
so we're having cereal with raspberries
I'm trying to keep the logs a consistent
length so I'm using this eight foot
plank as a measuring stick
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well there we go nice little shed I
deliberately used really thick logs
because I wanted this to be able to
withstand a tree falling on it but now
that I've built it I realized I just
made a giant Deadfall trap and this
thing falls down it would kill me
luckily it's pretty sturdy so I don't
think it's going to fall down and I'm
not living in it so should be okay
foreign
[Music]
well I didn't have to wait very long to
test it it's already starting to rain
this thing can get snowed on rained on
trees can fall on it I think it'll still
keep my stuff nice and sheltered and
safe well this rain is starting to pick
up I think I better get everything
cleaned up or it's going to get soaked
foreign
[Music]
checking out all the stuff fit in there
really nice with plenty of room it's
nice and waterproof so it won't get wet
and stay out of the elements but it's
too open to get mold or mice in there
it'll be nice I gotta clean out this
fire pit because it's turning into a
mountain of Ash but one good use for
fire Ash is to Mark foot paths if you
put a bunch of fire Ash on soil it kills
the grass and weeds and then it makes a
nice clear easy to follow footpath
foreign
that looks good enough for now foreign
[Music]
look at this this looks so much better
oh
we got plenty of firewood man I'm sad to
see all these trees down I really like
these trees but now that it's cleared
makes me think I need to do something
with it I've been talking to Becca maybe
we need to build like a little tiny home
or something I don't know but that's for
another video I need to pack up and get
out of here I miss my boys my wife well
listen guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you want to see more videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
make sure to click subscribe because we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching guys I'll
see you next Saturday if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
and you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
oh hey by the way I found a deer stand
on my property
and so I've set up a game camera here
and we're gonna see if there's any deer
around I might just do a hunting video
this fall